samuel l jackson reveals the one movie
role that changed everything it's the
first thing i ever did without a
substance in my body ET spoke with the
67 year-old lifetime achievement award
honoree on the silver carpet ahead of
sunday's b.e.t awards what does it mean
to be here tonight and being on you know
have a lifetime achievement award means
I've you know made a mark in this
business is there a favorite movie when
you look back there a moment did you say
this moment change well jungle fever
changed everything for me for real you
know that got me in the Hollywood and it
was a wonderful opportunity for me to
start something it was a very cathartic
change in my life I mean it's the first
thing I ever did without a substance in
my body and you know I've been pretty
much clean ever since and ascending so
it's been fine when do you start once
you become you know you once you're a
legend and you've been honored does that
mean it ends or do you keep going well
my thirst for creativity doesn't change
I want to get up and act every day
there's only a limited number of acting
opportunities in everybody's life I want
to make sure I get all mine Sam you've
gotten a lot of them I'm still chasing
you